austin i'll start with you on this one
because you've been a part of a number
of very big shows out there
which one of those experiences would you
say taught you the most about
co-headlining your own series
um i did this um
it's probably the one thing that i mean
obviously no one has watched because it
never got picked up but
i did this uh i did this pilot for
um the show called less than zero that's
based off of um
the bretty sinellis book and um
and i was i was playing that and i was
like super helpful
teacher for like what it was like to do
to lead like a television show even
though i only led one episode
but yeah i mean yeah so no one's no
one's
seen that but uh that was probably at
least for me personally the the one that
uh was like most helpful in that way i
hear you things happen for a reason and
it paved the way to this
midori i was stalking your instagram the
other day
and i saw that post you did and i was
just taken by how just sweet
sincere and honest it was and i do think
there is great value in
talking about some of the bumps in the
road and you had written that you had a
hard day sometimes and maybe sometimes
you didn't quite show up so
what yes or who was it that helped you
get over those moments and uh
forge forward with the process i see so
this is what they say about everything
you write becomes a new story i see now
um yeah so by that i meant that you know
you uh gosh when you're an actor and
you're working
17 hours a day sometimes and you're
frustrated with yourself or you're
you know trying to make this the best it
can be um you can sometimes lose sight
of the joy and the gratitude and so by
that i simply meant that
you know i'm super hard on myself as a
as are a lot of people
and i think looking back at the
experience you can always find times
when you're like oh man i
you know i i didn't really uh
i could have appreciated that day more
but
i'm going to pivot now and say that um
i feel like i feel like those days are
actually like really essential
to the whole process right like it's
you're making a painting and like every
day is a different stroke and like
they're not all going to be beautiful
and they're not all going to make sense
but we're playing human beings and
they're messy and they're complicated
and they make
mistakes so if it's all it's all good
less a news story and more something
that i think could really make a
difference for someone out there if
they're in that situation and need to
hear it from someone they admire from a
show so i appreciate you sharing that
another thing that crossed my mind
reading that post that i think you'll
you'll have a good answer to and austin
feel free to feel free to chime in here
as well
i often ask who is the unsung hero of a
production we know you guys we know the
directors the writers
not us yeah who's someone that
contributed just a little something
along the way that you think people need
to recognize more
god i mean my dresser olivia she was
like it's so funny like you can be so
self-absorbed with what you're doing
because you have you know you're
memorizing your lines and you're
focusing on what you're doing
but you forget everybody is doing a job
and
she was just always there for me if i
was cold if
my shirt was tucked in improperly but
she became more than that
she became my friend and like i could
always turn to her
and it it so much so that one day
actually austin you took her from me
for one of the shoots i think she went
with you and that whole day i was like
oh my god i don't know what to do
without olivia
but um i i truly like i look back at
that process and i just think of my
dresser olivia she's like the best
i bet for you austin anyone come to mind
i mean i don't know
to me i kind of like when you asked me
that question i just kind of thought of
like
whole crew as a collective like as a
whole um
and especially like um i feel like the
attitude that everyone has like if
everyone's like enjoying what they're
doing and like
what they're working on and also working
with one another it creates like
i mean it's a huge difference compared
to like if everyone is kind of like
dreading what they're doing
or not getting along with each other um
so it's almost like i don't know kind of
the energy of the whole crew and like
um although that's not really exactly
answered your question of the unsung
kind of hero i think unsung heroes is
everyone
you know as is everybody i feel like
the the family vibe on a set can be
really important so that still answers
the question there
yeah i mean it matters just like the
whole that everyone just
has a good attitude and it's just like
you know enjoying themselves really
makes all the difference i love the
holiday spirit in the show
whether it's christmas or any other
holiday what is the most
unique holiday tradition you two have
there's thanksgiving where
you the whole thing with the whole
family and all that kind of stuff i
don't know if i have any like
kind of weird somewhat i don't know
traditions that i could share i mean
they're all pretty
vanilla in a way how about you midori
anything come to mind
uh well yeah we always sing christmas
carols at my aunt colleen's house and
then
part of the tradition is that well as my
aunt's lips get more stained with red
wine
we then transition to elton john's um
tiny dancer
and we've done it every single year
since as long as i can remember so it
like starts with jingle bells
and then we're all like you know singing
tiny dancer
it's an eight o'clock transition right
there all right
to wind this down i am going to go into
spoiler territory we will put up
the the warning and save it for after
the show comes out
midori i cannot ask you i cannot not ask
you about
your dance moves in episode three any of
that choreographed and if not
where like what is kind of creating that
style
for her totally so oh my god i was so
nervous about this because i'm not a
dancer and i
truly am not just saying this like i'm
scared to dance in front of people
but um the joke who worked on uh
joe tratts who work on worked on be more
chill um
he brought in some of his choreographers
and they helped me with some of the
moves
but they all started from like an
organic place so they would let me fool
around
and i think uh i don't know one time i
just like started swinging my legs and i
was like do you guys like this and they
were like yeah we actually really like
that
um and i feel like under anybody else's
direction because ma
pamela was directing that episode
anybody else
might have uh came in with some notes
but she
and the choreographers were so open to
it being as weird
and as ugly as possible i mean one of
the moves is literally me punching
people
um and so yeah it it went from being a
scary moment to truly like one of the
best moments for me on set
as someone who can't dance and is
terrified to dance in front of people
that spoke to me so i appreciate it i
had so many more but i already got the
wrap so
i gotta let you guys go but again huge
congratulations on the show and thanks
so much for your time today
thank you bye